oh did I get her better Oh God hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to mortal now I don't know about
you but something seems a little bit
disconcerting about this here intro here
namely this late alright whatever I need
to get in this game so we're gonna find
out what girl she can find more tomb at
least ten times otherwise you lose gets
ready to run you need to hide in the
closet after each point why am I doing
this why am I doing this
why would I do this oh ow looks based
over the closet under the closet turn
off the flashlight what what what what
what let's pace over it's not working oh
god I don't wanna hi who came more
tomorrow okay okay alrighty then
hey you want to play games with me huh
I'm ready for you
bring it on boredom I'm gonna find you
in our weird game of hide-and-seek that
I didn't volunteer to play with you and
do that this closet no there's more to
me with more to Morton Norton where are
you Mawson oh okay alright then
hello mortem Mortimer where are you hey
I didn't do that I didn't do that
okay no they're gone they're ones there
okay all right thing so I gotta do this
janky-ass thing and yeah that don't work
yeah I don't work at all with that if I
didn't do that looking what's going on
here more them come on
oh boy hi
okay oh yeah this looks bad gasps looks
bad boredom boredom boredom boredom
Poornima more Tom poram mordom Hey okay
all right fine close it and close it
okay I got it buddy
oh is this the closet that I need to
hide it by mordom okay why I don't get
it
she's right there with the [ __ ] boredom
hi how are you doing nice vest and hat
of God
yeah mom oh okay alright then I died all
right okay I get it okay that was bad I
get it okay all right then I don't know
what happened I think mortem got stuck
when you see you're standing still right
clicker and run the closet only opens
Wow
ah so I have to go back to that
particular closet okay I get it
it is a perverse game of hide-and-seek
okay I didn't do that okay are you there
huh
what the [ __ ] don't do that to me don't
do that I don't like that at all
[ __ ] you all of you okay alright she
downstairs I don't like this game I
don't like this game I don't like it I
mean the games fine itself I'm just
talking about I don't like the game of
hide-and-seek in the darkness it's a bit
of the opposite of what I'd rather do
with my time boredom oh did I get her
I did get her oh god oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me
oh [ __ ] me I'm in the wrong area by
boredom
hi I'm autumn no I come [ __ ]
morning you got to be up here you got to
be up y'all get on like that yeah I
don't like that morning
oh we're gonna [ __ ] are you more numb
doing here for theater hi okay all right
she's in there but what do I do about
that
here we go [ __ ] god stop that good so
open the door
oh god oh god oh god I can't wear that
boy can I wear my oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god get
in there get in get in get in get turn
off how do I turn turned off I don't
know what I did
[Music]
okay I think I did bad that's good
alright I don't know where the [ __ ] she
would have gone now okay okay all right
then I mean you're near I mean I'm close
by
oh hey oh ho ho ah me know like that
okay guys didn't get her I didn't get
her cocky there there we go they've all
gotten so weird he's faced open big
space open I'd like to open this down
please please please please please can I
open this okay
I did apparently hey how are you doing
there I got my strangly grabbers ready
if you come through this I'm ready to
strangle anybody home for a strangling
[Applause]
I'm gonna guess that's the all-clear
signal not 100% sure about that but I
want to guess okay
alrighty then oh okay alrighty then can
i okay hey [ __ ] god dammit
got ya back not here okay I'm a bit
concerned now whoa would you do that why
would you do that
well [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] me too
okay open the goddamn door hey [ __ ] you
god damn it oh it's impossible so anyway
that's all the time that I got for this
one I'm gonna take a little bit of a
breather because my voice seems to be
fragile as a baby right now so I'm gonna
let mordom live for just a little bit
longer while I figure out a strategy to
eat I mean I could figure it out but it
to get that 10 times in a row and not be
screwed over by the doors gonna be a bit
of an indie trip so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think down the comments below and if
you want to beat it put a link to the
game in the description as well the demo
is free right now so go right ahead and
play with Mortimer's so thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next people bye-bye
[Music]